-Our next guest is a very
talented actress who stars in
the Apple TV+ show
"Mythic Quest."
New episodes stream on
Apple TV+ Fridays.
Let's take a look.
-Why did you think
that I needed cheering up?
-Oh, well,
'cause your family hates you
and you have nowhere to go.
-Where did you get that from?
My family love me.
They, just --
They're in Melbourne.
It's a 16-hour flight, so...
-They went to Hawaii
and didn't invite you.
-Yes, but the Airbnb
had limited beds,
and so, we all -- On the
group chat, they told me --
-There was a two-day layover
in San Diego.
-Whatever. You're spending
Christmas alone, too.
-Well, I don't really do family.
-Uh, more like
family doesn't do you.
Ask your son.
-Please welcome to the show
Charlotte Nicdao, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi!
-I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
Thanks for having me.
-Yeah. You're welcome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a very funny show
about the world of
video-game developing.
How much did you know
about gaming and game design?
-Not a lot.
-Okay.
-I'm ashamed to say.
I did -- It was not a world
that I was super-familiar with.
-I don't think you have to be
ashamed about that, FYI.
-Oh, good. Thank you.
You know what?
I'm letting the shame go then.
It's gone. Yeah.
-Great. You know what?
That's the least
we can do for you.
-Okay, so I'm done here now.
-Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you. I'm sorry.
I didn't think
it would be this fast.
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you have to --
Did you enjoy the research?
-I really did.
You know, right after
I got cast on the show,
I had to go back to Australia.
And I was like, "I'm going to
get some research done
while I'm here before I go back
and shoot the first season."
And I went for a check-up with
my doctor, and she was like,
"Hey, you know how you got
that pap smear
before you went to L.A.?
You failed."
-Oh, wow.
-It was a bad one.
-Okay.
-And I was like --
-I didn't know they
were pass/fail.
-I didn't know either.
It was a shock to me.
She was like,
"You got to go to hospital.
They're putting you under
a general anesthetic.
And there gonna,
like, sort that out."
And I was like,
"Okay, I don't want to do that.
I'm afraid."
And my husband was like,
"You have to."
This is an
important lesson, guys.
You got to take care of
your health.
He was like, "You have to.
If you go and do this thing
and go under
your general anesthetic,
on the way home,
we can buy a Nintendo Switch."
Like, bribing me
like I'm a child.
I was like, "Alright.
Fine, let's go."
So I went.
I went under
the general anesthetic.
I woke up -- I don't know if --
Have you ever been
under general anesthetic before?
-Yes.
-It's really scary.
-It is.
-You do the countdown
and then you get to five
and then you wake up
and you think you're in
"Grey's Anatomy,"
which is what I said to
the lovely nurse
who was standing by me.
I was like,
"I'm in 'Grey's Anatomy.'"
-And she was like, "No, no,
you're just in the hospital."
I was like, "Where's my doctor?"
And she was like,
"He's doing another surgery."
I was like, "What's his name?"
She was like, "Dr. Derek."
"Like Grey's Anatomy'?!"
And she was like,
"Yeah, look, you seem fine.
I'm gonna go."
I was like, "Wait, wait, wait.
I've got to tell you something.
She was like,
"What do you have to tell me?
I was like, "On the way home,
I'm getting a Nintendo Switch."
And then I sat on the couch
for way longer
than I really needed to playing
my Nintendo Switch.
-Well, you're wonderful
in the show,
so any research
you put into it --
-No, that was
a really important part of
the character development, yeah.
-Absolutely.
Now, I know your father is
an actor, as well.
So you came from
a family that's in the arts.
Has he been able to come --
Has he visited set?
-Yeah, he came out
when we were shooting Season 1.
And, like,
he's such a character.
He's extremely charismatic.
It's kind of annoying.
It's like, every time
I introduce him
to one of my friends,
he ends up being one of
their friends
and I'm, like, Al's daughter.
And I brought him on set,
and we were shooting
kind of a serious scene
at the end of the season.
And I went off to shoot
this dramatic scene.
And I came back ready to see
my dad be really proud of me.
And he was standing in front of
the monitor, like,
doing a stand-up routine for all
the producers at video village.
And I was like, "Dad, sit down."
-Well, I'm sure
he's also very proud of you.
But you know when an actor
gets an audience,
they have to perform.
-He's -- After he left,
all the producers were like,
"We see where you get it from."
-Oh, that's very nice.
But that wasn't
your original plan.
You were going to be
an orchestral clarinetist?
-Yeah. I studied music,
like, for a long time.
I very seriously wanted to be
a musician.
-Whoo!
-Yeah, whoo! Music!
Lots of music fans
in the crowd tonight.
-Were you a
very talented clarinetist?
-No, I was not good.
That's the main reason
I didn't --
-That's the main reason you
got out of it? Yeah.
-I need a lot of praise,
you know?
And I wasn't getting enough.
I was like, "Where can I go
where I get, like,
a lot of compliments
all the time"?
-Yeah, everything I've seen
about orchestral musicians,
you never see them
getting a lot of praise.
-No, no.
They get, like,
that huge applause
at the end of a performance,
and then, I mean, is that it?
-Yeah, I think that's about it.
-That's that all I ever got.
I got, like, an obligatory clap,
and then people would be like,
"Okay, that's enough.
Get off the stage."
-But you also -- It should be
noted you also were in a band.
-I was, yes.
-What was the
name of your group?
-It's called Charlotte Nicdao
and the Sloth Orchestra.
-The Sloth Orchestra?
-Uh-huh.
-And what were the
Sloth Orchestra shows like?
-Well, my whole thing
with this band was that
I had studied classical and then
jazz music very seriously
for a very long time.
After I decided not to do that
anymore, I was like,
"Like, what's the most fun
version of being a musician?"
And it was
drinking a lot of wine,
which I think you can see.
One of those photos,
I'm raising a glass.
-Yeah, It should be noted,
not trying to
keep it on the down low.
-This is not a sober woman.
-No, no, that is not.
-It was like a big party where
I would, like, sing like
I was a toddler with a crown on.
-Yeah.
-It was a lot of fun.
-That's a big difference,
again, to go back --
I've never seen an
orchestral clarinetist
have a glass of wine with that.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Well, you can't.
It will mess up your reed, Seth.
-It will mess up your reed. See?
You obviously know a lot more
about music than I do.
-That's all that I know.
-You had a cool thing --
-Reeds.
-You got to day one,
where they were like,
"And, obviously,
this goes without saying.
The wine will
mess up your reed."
This is pretty cool.
Explain this real quick.
-So, this season's
small spoiler alert.
-Small.
-Small, small.
-Allowable spoiler.
-Tiny. I cleared it.
We do an episode where you see
my character, Poppy,
as a young child
growing up in Australia,
which is really exciting to get
to watch the team put together,
because they made a family
that looked just like
my Australian-Filipino family,
which was really cool.
And the actress that they cast
to play Poppy's mom
is actually
a really close friend of mine,
Hayley Magnus.
She -- I was a bridesmaid
at her wedding.
This is us at
her bachelorette party.
And now when we hang out,
we call it mother-daughter time.
-That's really great.
That's, like, borderline creepy,
but mostly really great.
-It's kind of creepy
and kind of sweet.
-You're so wonderful in the
show, which I love a great deal,
and I'm so happy
to have you here.
Thank you so much
for making time for us.
-Thank you so much.
-You guys,
that's Charlotte Nicdao.
New episodes of "Mythic Quest"
stream Fridays on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back.